hey youtubers you guys have been asking
me for new thor ragnarok so I figured
I'd talk about the guardians of the
galaxy crossover element Kevin Feige
clarified a few things about the end of
guardians of the galaxy - that connected
to Thor Ragnarok and it really
roundabout way so if you missed that
part of the movie or you don't know
what's going on I'll try to explain it's
actually pretty cool and it's a little
bit funny there's a new round of the
Marvel giveaway - and I'm going back to
the spider-man action figures for these
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so you may have heard the Kevin Feige
clarify that they changed the way they
allow Marvel movies to cross over
I know blasphemy not allowing Marvel
movies to cross over that's part of the
reason why we go see Marvel movies
because they're so connected well you
still have people like Robert Downey jr.
showing up in spider-man you have Hulk's
showing up during Thor Ragnarok they're
still doing crossovers like that but
what he said that they've changed now in
Phase three is that the movies are
overlapping less so like at the end of
Iron Man 2 you see this big scene with
Thor's hammer that he's at the next film
it lets you know exactly what's
happening they said that they're doing
that less and less just because they
don't have to anymore but that doesn't
mean that they're not doing crossover
stuff but hopefully you stayed through
the credits and you spotted a really big
thor ragnarok crossover there was
another one that you may have missed
during the movie and Kevin Feige
clarified the bigger one the bigger one
I'll talk about first so if you don't
know who this is this is Jeff Goldblum's
Grand Master character he seems kind of
ridiculous but don't let that fool you
he is a crazy powerful character from
the comics but the other one you may
have missed was Korg during the big jump
sequences they were making the 700 jumps
to get to ego it was mostly about doing
this comedy set piece that made it look
kind of like a video game
you got to see Stan Lee during one of
the stops that made everybody in my
theater crapped their pants during
another stop you got to see Korg bashing
another member of his race on a derelict
rock just in the middle of space he is a
huge Thor character he's going to be in
Thor Ragnarok is one of Hulk's warbound
if you've never read the Planet Hulk
storyline or have you never seen the
animated version of the movie he's just
a member of this race they also included
a member of his race during Thor the
dark world he was the guy that Thor
reduced to rubble at the beginning of
the film
Oh y'all
thanks chef Joe Saranda anyone else
they're going to have another version of
that scene during thor ragnarok where
he's warming up in the arena finding his
way up the ladder till he gets to his
friend hole so Korg is going to be like
the warm-up match but he's being played
by Tiger Woods he D the director of the
movie so it's a big Easter egg and thor
ragnarok but it also serves as a big
point a crossover for guardians of the
galaxy the grand master elders of the
universe crossover is way more subtle
but it's actually a much much bigger
deal you may have noticed that the
collector is nowhere to be found during
guardians of the galaxy - they just
didn't use Benicio del Toro he has been
seen on the set during infinity war so
he'll be back in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe for the really big stuff but if
you're a big Disney fan you may have
spotted the collector's fortress in the
background of the thor ragnarok trailer
on Sekar so the planets a car in the
movie Thor Ragnarok is very different
from the comic book version of the
planet in the comic book it's ruled over
by this despot called the Red King in
the movie it's ruled over by the
Grandmaster Jeff Goldblum who just holds
these elaborate games and you see all
these Jack Kirby visuals in the
background implying that there's a lot
of big people that frequent the planet
when he's sitting here in his office
talking to Valkyrie about what did you
bring me and she's very clearly wheeled
up Thor I brought you a contender in the
background of this shot you can actually
spot the Collector's fortress so the
collectors fortress is not the place
that you spotted in nowhere where the
Guardians took the power stone to him he
has a fortress that's much bigger more
elaborate and they turned it into a ride
at Disneyland it's going to open this
summer the Disney rides stuff in real
life is a little bit different like they
work all kinds of stuff from the Marvel
movies into there they're a whole bunch
of Easter eggs in
his fortress like what is he collecting
it's meant to be this self-contained
interactive story but this is what it
looks like in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so the collector in the
Grandmaster are brothers not so much in
the blood sense more in the fraternity
sense in that they are some of the
oldest living beings in the universe now
not quite as old as ego the Living
Planet as he says he's a celestial so
he's one of the first beings ever but as
you probably remember the collector is
hardcore about collecting all of the
Infinity stones now he obviously wants
to wield the power for himself do not be
fooled by space Liberace he's also very
powerful and very dangerous we don't
know exactly where the Infinity gem is
going to show up during Thor Ragnarok
but very clearly a gem is in play the
collector is going to have knowledge of
it there'll be some minor elements of
crossover in that sense when we get a
little bit closer we'll talk more about
the elders of the universe they're
really weird people and now that we know
Celestials exist in the universe they're
still alive if egos still alive then
there's got to be some other Celestials
that are still alive out there somewhere
so the more space-based movies we get
the more celestial beings we'll probably
meet but the elders of the universe even
though they each have their own goals
tend to work together when it suits
their needs they even tried to bring the
infinity gems together in the comics to
get rid of Galactus I know everybody
wants to see the Netflix series
crossover with the movies well the
Grandmaster actually used the defenders
against one of dr. Doom's robots called
the prime defender now obviously there's
a big problem because you can't do dr.
doom characters but there have been
times in the comics when grand cosmic
beings have influenced the lives of the
street-level heroes and taken them on
crazy adventures so there's always
opportunities for them to do really
outlandish stuff even if the Netflix
series are staying relatively grounded
right now the big bad of the Netflix
series is actually going to be Sigourney
Weaver's character she's the head of the
hand organization so as mystical as the
hand has gotten with resurrecting people
that's about as crazy as it's going to
get on the TV shows for now but he has a
really funny reason why Kevin Feige said
that they added Jeff Goldblum to the end
of guardians of the galaxy to is because
they're like okay he's going to be in
Thor Ragnarok he's the brother of the
collector of a Guardians character and
we have all this footage of him
dancing so why don't we just stick it on
there for fun in a sort of a wink to
that connection so I love the idea of
Marvel doing Easter eggs just because
they're funny even if they have very
important implications for the next
movie which James Gunn kind of implied
when there was a big set visit a bunch
of journalists went and they were
talking about post-credit scenes and he
said you know what I think of
post-credit scenes is a really fun
opportunity to do dumb just do the
dumbest most funny thing you could think
to do so that's how you get to stuff
like teenage Groot that's how you get
Sylvester Stallone in the original
guardians but I've already done a big
Guardians post-credits video so I'll
link that at the end of this because so
much stuff happened during that
seriously if you haven't seen that movie
please go see it it is crazy what's
going to happen next is the showrunners
confirm some really big stuff about the
villains next season for arrow and flash
so I'll do a video for that but I have
new spider-man homecoming previews that
I'll probably try to do in the next
couple days there's a whole bunch of
stuff happening on Sunday so I'll try to
get that stuff out as fast as possible
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner
Gabriel Gibran please private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details while you wait
for that click here for all those
guardians post credits and click here
for brand new spider-man thank you so
much for watching plus high five I'll
see you guys tonight